hallo mein name ist luca hat meine
lieben freunde ich habe vor einigen
monaten ein video auf einem kanal
hochgeladen namens ich bestelle das
teuerste produkt von louie vito ein
kurzer ausschnitt um euch das video kurz
zusammenzufassen stand jetzt finde ich
jedes produkt hat hässlich in dem video
war ich auf der website von louis vitton
unterwegs haben alle möglichen
kategorien durchgeschaut mir alle
produkte angesehen und schlussendlich
drei produkte ausgewählt von denen ihr
eines bestimmen durften dass ich mir
dann bestellen sollte will tippt leather
down blau sortiert und reversibel länder
aid kit von den drei produkten hat dann
mit gehörigem abstand die reverse
blätter aviator jacket gewonnen ich hab
dann auf jeden fall zwei drei tage nach
dem upload des videos noch mal in die
umfrage rein geschaut habe dann halt
gesehen dass der wm ticket vorne ist und
bin dementsprechend auf die louis vitton
webseite gegangen um dort das hier lesen
zu müssen
dieses produkt können sie ausschließlich
telefonisch bestellen oder in einem
louis vitton geschäfte erwerben da
dachte ich mir dann halt erstmal handys
ausverkauft und das dauert bis die
wieder auf lager ist 23 monate später
bin ich dann wieder auf die louis vitton
webseite gegangen die dann auch ein
komplett neues design irgendwie hatte
und ihr seht es hier schon eingeblendet
meine damen und herren auf der website
stand auch dann immer noch dieses
produkt können sie ausschließlich
telefonisch bestellen oder in einem
louis vitton geschäft erwerben
ich hab mir dann gedacht hey bevor ich
da anrufe euch doch erstmal ob im louis
vitton store hier in köln diese jacke
verfügbar ist und nein
ja natürlich ist sie dort auch nicht
verfügbar gewesen nicht dann also
dementsprechend gegoogelt louis vitton
kundenservice da kam auch diese nummern
hier und die habe ich dann angerufen und
ihr seht auch schon hier dass ich
tatsächlich mit dieser nummer nur vier
minuten telefoniert habe aber es waren
die krassesten vier minuten
kundenservice erfahrung die ich je
gemacht habe diese tante alter das war
so richtig wie man sich so eine louis
vitton rostocker verkäuferin vorstellen
das ist verstehe ich würde nicht falls
sie war unfassbar freundlich und
unfassbar kompetent auch die wusste über
alles mögliche bescheid
ich hatte nur mal eine erfahrung in dem
nur vitor store in berlin hätte ich eine
jogginghose an
dann freut mich da einfach nur umschauen
und wozu aus dem laden rausgeekelt weil
die meinten ey was ist das fünfteilige
also das personal das in solchen
hochpreisigen luxus kleidungs
unternehmen stores inc arbeitet die sind
oft sehr aufs äußerste äußerlich bedacht
ihr wisst was ich meine
ich habe wirklich noch nie eine
verkäuferin so böse angeguckt wie getan
indem louis wie thorsten der lieben vor
drei jahren deswegen hatte ich als eine
gewisse abneigung davor bei diesem laden
anzurufen m hat das auf jeden fall dann
allerdings dennoch gemacht und es war
wirklich der hammer
die hat mich über alles informiert das
war wirklich anders war als hätte ich
mit einer göttin geredet immer mit der
ruhe
lange rede kurzer sinn dieses produkt
kann man auf jeden fall nur online
bestellen weil es teuer ist und die halt
nicht wollen dass man dann die ganzen
daten und das ist gedanken dass die auch
dass die den vorgänger ja weiter in der
geschichte sie hat dann auf jeden fall
gefragt ja sie interessieren sich dann
also für die nba jacket das ist ja echt
ein wunderbares exemplar wie groß sind
sie dennoch nicht an so gesagt so 193
und ja dann würde ich die größe
empfehlen und ich sind immer mehr so
das ist eigentlich nur von youtube video
ich weiß nicht ob ich noch mal das video
erinnern können allerdings habe ich mir
auch mal das teuerste produkt auf der
website von gucci bestellt ich richtig
so
hier konnte ich mir dann auf jeden fall
komplett normal in dem online
bestellvorgang bestellt die kam dann
zwei drei werktage später an ich habe
alle schilder angelassen alle preis
sachen et cetera pp hab es dann wieder
zurückgeschickt weil na ja schon recht
herzlich ein louis wie torwart das ganze
jetzt allerdings ein bisschen anders und
dann hat sie mir immer mehr fragen
gestellt meinte lanz ja wie wollen sie
denn sein und so weiter und so fort und
dann hab ich halt irgendwann gesagt hey
weil die dame war auch wirklich echt
sehr freundlich habe dann auf jeden fall
gesagt hey ich bin youtube oder 1000
likes bestelle ich mir eines der
teuersten produkte von louie vito rund
mich wollte die eigentlich noch mal
anprobieren in meinem video und
höchstwahrscheinlich zurück sind und
habe einfach komplexe die wahrheit
ausgeplaudert und da meinte sie halt
dass das sich für die halt überhaupt
nicht lohnt weil rücksendungen retouren
alles mögliche blabla style kostenlos
und dann schicken sie mir so ein fettes
ding und müssen dann halt die
versandkosten zahlen und das ist ja auch
komplett verständlich dass auf jeden
fall jetzt mal eben die komplette
situation nochmal zusammengefasst weil
ich habe unfassbar viele kommentare
unter dem louis vitor video gesehen von
wegen luca das video 100.000 likes was
sie noch immer nicht jacke bestellt
allerdings ihr tier ist bereits in
diesem video hier auch schon im titel
eingeblendet es geht heute nicht nur
darum dass ich erzähle dass ich das
nicht gemacht habe mit der neue vito
jacke sondern ich meine damen und herren
besteller heute das günstigste produkt
bei gucci und verlose es an euch
ich dachte hey wenn ich euch schon die
komplette story hier erzähle dann kann
ich euch option zumindest noch irgendwie
was verlosen oder irgendwie sowas war
als entschuldigung mehr oder weniger und
naja schauen uns heute mal ein bisschen
auf der website von gucci hier um
ich bin hier bei herrenbekleidung
herrenschuhe das wird alles unfassbar
teuer sein tücher okay das könnte
günstig seien 400 euro für ein scheiß du
also schauen wir mal weiter im schmuck
wird auf jeden fall teuer sein und
sonnenbrillen werden auch teuer sein das
habe ich erst das was oder irgend sowas
rosen und schwarz hört sich gut an ist
aber noch accessoires komplett dann
schaue ich mir das auch noch an und
sorgten direkt auch nochmal weil socken
dürften eigentlich nicht so teuer sein
ich habe hundert euro für ein paar
socken ich weiß dass ich selber auch
teilweise teure klamotten 3 250 euro
die siehst du halt nicht mal wir haben
wir 90 euro teure socken hier unten
wieder 100 euro also ich glaube das
günstigste produkt sind bisher wirklich
diese gut schießen aus baumwolle für 90
euro ach du scheiße sind die land okay
wir schauen mal
bei den herren accessoires haben wir
portemonnaies gürtel brille modeschmuck
uhren und krawatten m krawatten würde
ich sagen sie nicht so teuer
schmuck ist wieder sehr sehr teuer und
portemonnaie jacke mal gucken sie
allerdings noch mal kurz bei den
krawatten rein 160 geht's los sie sind
alle die kosten durch alle 160 euro ja
genau die hier unten auch alle 160 euro
dann habe ich hier noch hosen die sind
680 980 euro ja ich dachte dass rosen
tatsächlich werde t shirt sich jetzt
kann auch sein also die t shirts fangen
auch alle bei 300 400 euro an das ist ja
übertrieben
dann habe ich hier noch slippers die
sind 460 euro ich könnte noch mal hier
bei den kindersachen gucken was die hier
alles so haben mag ich auch mal bei
jungen hier selbst bei den jungen kostet
so ein politischer 4
das ding ist ja auch kinder tragen so
was ja dann vielleicht ein zwei jahre
die wachsen ja noch länger hier sind
schuhe für ein kind wie auch die 270
euro meine füße waren ausgewachsen da
war ich 18 700 euro
sie soll so eine kinderjacke aus wolle
mit patches
kinder rucksack für die schule für fast
1000 euro mensch nicht gesenkt ziemlich
abstoßen also ich glaube die kinderseite
können wir ausschließen haben hier die t
shirts können wir auch zu machen und ich
glaube es werden dann ja ich glaube es
werden dann halt wirklich diese gut
stockum ich glaube die größe m passt auf
jeden fall den meisten leuten das heißt
ich gehe jetzt einfach mal auf in den
warenkorb legen
klickt man auf zur kasse wiederkehrender
kunde ja schön wär's alter vielen dank
für ihre bestellung
ich habe gerade für 90 euro ein paar
socken bestellt was ich nicht mal haben
werde sondern euch was denken werde ich
werde in diesem video hier beide bei
nicht so machen dass sich das video hier
jetzt beenden werde und dann sehen wir
uns irgendwie in ein paar tagen wieder
wenn das produkt angekommen ist sondern
wir sehen uns jetzt gleich sofort wieder
einige tage sind vergangen meine liebe
freunde und dieses paket ist heute und
da nie angekommen
absender e commerce also ich glaube dass
mit seiner ständigen empire auspackt das
warum die kirche bisher sind wenn jeder
die suppen drin sind also darum für die
tüte gut ski die brauche ich
wir haben auf jeden fall so ein kleines
paket drin das kann ich jetzt mal eben
hier so schön aus da muss schon sagen
verpackungsdesign schon mit schon bei 90
euro sorgten
zudem verhöhnte
also probieren wir die socken gibt mal
an der kms ist die kleine begrüßte ich
eigentlich schuhgröße 40 reduziert sich
so um den dreh ich habe jetzt aber ende
stellen und england
ich muss wirklich sagen diesen hardcore
e-mail oder ich hab's ja gesagt er will
stellt das fühlt sich so produkt bei
gucci und ich kann lohse ist auch an
euch
von daher werde ich diese sorgten jetzt
mal wieder ausziehen und werde die
natürlich an euch verlosen bz einen von
euch wenn ich ebenfalls zum verschenken
würde begleiter ich dachte sie sollen
jetzt auf jeden fall wieder in dieser
verpackung rein dann zusammen mit den
ganzen schildchen also wenn die einer
feuchten wänden sollte dann hat er auf
jeden fall am start habe ich dieses
komische bändchen hier noch darum das
einfach sogar meinen ihr fragt euch
jetzt allerdings wahrscheinlich heyo k
wie kann ich denn dieses open gewinnen
gute frage probiert bei den youtube
kanal kommentiert unter diesem video
euren instagram nahmen damit
kontaktieren kann und folgen doch intern
also das sind die sachen wenn ihr die
drei sachen umsetzen könnte
sein dass wir 90 euro gut die socken
bekommen werde komme ich unterschreibe
mal die gute tüte kommt dann auf jeden
fall wieder hier rein ich wünsche euch
auf jeden fall ganz ganz ganz ganz viel
glück
es war auf jeden fall echt spaßig sich
diese sorten zu bestellen
ich wünsche euch auf jeden fall viel
glück bei diesem gewinnspiel jetzt hier
heute meine damen und herren hat mich
wetters irgendwann demnächst dann
auflösen und die person dann über
instagram anschreiben und ja aber nicht
bei den kanal wenn es euch gefallen hat
lassen daumen hoch da kommentiert mal
was eure lieblings marke ist unschön
[Musik]